الى الجانب الاخر الان من المعادله مجله
نيوزويك نشرت تقريرا اعتبرت فيه ان المجر
وعبر رئيس وزرائها فيكتور اوربن قد تشكل
بمواقفها بسيطه امل لبوتين في ازمه
اوكرانيا الحديث هنا عن الناتو والعضوين
الجديدين المفترضين فنلندا والسويد
والانضمام للحلف لابد ان توافق برلمانات
الدول الاعضاء على ضم الدولتين وباجماع 30
دوله وفي العاصمه اجل البرلمان المجري مره
اخرى التصويت على انضمام فنلندا والسويد
للنيتو رئيس الوزراء المجري اتخذ خلال
فتره توليه السلطه خطابا متمردا على
الاجماع الاوروبي كما كانت له مواقف
متعاطفه مع موسكو اضافه لتعطيل عقوبات
الاتحاد الاوروبي ويوم الثامن عشر من
الشهر الماضي خلال خطابه عن حالات الامه
اعتبر اوربن ان الغرب لم يعزل الصراع في
اوكرانيا فقط بل نشره الى عموم قاره
اوروبا مضيفا ان حلفاء اوكرانيا
تعهد خلال كلمته بالحفاظ على العلاقات مع
روسيا كما طالبت دول الاوروبيه بالشيء
نفسه لانه دون علاقات بحسب اوربن لن يكون
هناك وقف اطلاق النار ولا محادثات سلام
التقت خبراء في الشؤون المجاريه وقالوا ان
مشاكسات قرب مع الناتو والاتحاد الاوروبي
جزء من القتال بين بروكسل وبودابست كما
انها من جانب اخر قد تكون محاوله لشراء
رضاء روسيا التي تعد واحده من اكبر موردي
الطاقه في المجر اضاف الخبراء ان خطاب
رئيس وزراء المجر هو موجه بشكل اكبر
للداخل خاصه في الملف الاوكراني لكنه عاده
ما يسقط تهديدات الفيتو في اللحظه الاخيره
نظرا لاعتماد المجر الاقتصادي على الاتحاد
الاوروبي ولان اوربن يعرف من يدفع فواتير
المجر ودائما بحسب التقرير
يحاول الاوكرانيون اقناع اوروبا بان روسيا
لن تتوقف حتى المحيط الاطلسي لكن المجريين
لا يقتنعون بهذه التهديدات العالم كله راى
ان الجيش الروسي ليس في وضع يسمح له
بمهاجمه النيتو ولن يكون كذلك لبعض الوقت